what if a group of women decided that
they live to live outside of society hi
I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with and Fortier
she's the New York Times bestselling
author of Juliet a novel and she's got a
new book out called the lost sisterhood
which is about ancient Amazons and
contemporary academics and thanks for
joining us thank you so much for having
me why did you decide to write about
Amazon's and academics well I am a bit
of an academic myself I have to confess
and Amazons I think the I've been
interested in Amazon's for a long long
time and I think that I might be a
little anachronistic but I think it's
simply that as a woman when you reach
back in history and you try to find
freedom-loving women right well
obviously the most freedom-loving women
ever in the history of mythology or
whatever so is this a good time to be in
Amazon or to do modern women need
Amazons because there seems to have been
you know a kind of at least on a general
level there's equality of opportunity
equality of outcomes certainly at the
higher level of kind of business and
politics your Danish of Danish descent
there's a prime minister of Denmark is
as a woman so why do we do we need
Amazons anymore do we need them more
than ever I still think that that
there's a greater physical inequality
and we can't really do anything about
that and unless we start searchin
ethically modifying right women and I'm
not sure you want to do that you know so
so the story that I'm telling is this a
very physical story there's a lot to do
with being in shape in physical shape
and and through that finding a strength
to also mentally be look for equality
and so on so there is that it has to be
that when you're talking about these
well I mean and that's interesting and
to talk a little bit about the book I
mean basically it's a it's a woman
an academic at Oxford who is kind of
obsessed with Amazon's and then she
starts finding clues to a kind of
ancient archaeological digs about
Amazon's in North Africa in the
Mediterranean and it goes back and forth
between story of Amazon's in the past as
well as the contemporary academic and
you know one of the things that's
fascinating about the book and I'm
thinking since something like Umberto
eCos the name of the Rose which came out
in 1980 you know and through things like
The Da Vinci Code by Dan Brown Philippa
Gregory's you know massively popular
historical fictions
what's the this seems to be a great time
for historical fiction that is seriously
researched as well as like really you
know good plots in action why do you
think we're so interested in delving
back not just into the past but into a
really richly detailed research past
well I do think that that human being
it's a very good sign I think that we're
interested in the past because in the
past we can see a lot of answers I think
or certainly a lot of warning signs
about how to not proceed right in the
present I do also think that in this day
and age you know anybody in our society
has the money to buy a book it's about
priorities you might choose not to spend
your money on a book but anybody may do
so time is another matter so for someone
to actually pick up a book and you know
that yourself and I know that and
anybody who sees this isn't worth it
right
am I really going to invest that much
time in this book has to be pretty good
value right so so we want something that
teaches us us something it can't just be
entertainment it has to it has to have
some solid historical you know wait so I
mean part of historical fiction I mean
and the creation of a world that we can
really inhabit at least imaginative Lee
as part of the value proposition of
contemporary literature I think so and
even though we have all sorts of 3d
things and film now and you know all
these electronic ways of recreating the
past and even imagine
well I still do think that you don't
quite get people you don't quite make
people walk in the ancient world unless
they do it through a narrative where
they can identify with the characters
and I think that a book ma more so than
then images will actually allow people
you know individually to enter that
ancient so you're not a lot of authors
you know complain and [ __ ] and moan all
the time about you know and not without
reason about how you know nobody reads
anymore etc I mean you've found
obviously Juliet was a was a
best-selling book so that did well but
you you're not worried about the the
future of print because you think it
provides something unique for
contemporary readers well and this is
why we should applaud people like Dan
Brown you know I met so many people on
airplanes you know men in particular we
said I haven't touched a novel in 20
years I'm reading again and and and they
have rediscovered the joy of reading and
and the riches you can find right even
in fiction well I know I well are
especially in fiction right we should
say I've went to grad school because I
was reading novels all the time and then
when I got to grad school I was like I I
don't have time to read so I understand
the time pressure talk about your decks
book not to get ahead of the lost
sisterhood but you will be moving to a
different time a historical time just
briefly sketch that for us exactly we're
going to Paris in the next one past and
present and and I just had a meeting
with the editor yesterday and and we're
still this is Catherine de Medicis Paris
it is it is Catherine de Medici spirits
and you just what I find so interesting
about Paris at this time is that this is
a time when there's great political
opposition against this the whole
menagerie of of the leadership it was
later or even at the time dismissed as a
religious skirmish between Catholics and
Protestants but really just a political
disagreement and a furious resistance
and it culminates in the st.
Bartholomew's night massacre which I
would argue is more of a political thing
and this of course is one of the most
famous slaughters of Protestants by you
know Catholic forces exactly and so what
I look so much forward to doing with
this book is to show it is not so much
driven by the church it's not the church
that's the great villain of the
Inquisition this is political leaders
who see this as a convenient tool to to
stir up resentment to seize people's
property because that's what you could
do if someone was you know convicted
even before the trial you could just
seize their property because these
recent kings and queens were desperate
for money at that time is classical
scenario so I just can't wait to get
started looking and that'll like the
lawsuit sure it'll go back and forth now
let's talk a little bit about ideas
because your work combines history you
know plot and ideas that are
specifically kind of libertarian or
classical liberal I mean they're about
limits on state power the ways in which
you know certain individual rights get
trampled how did you come to your views
about what we have reasoned like to call
free minds and free markets and why is
fiction a particularly good way to
explore them well I was a late bloomer
in many ways and certainly politically
because I grew up in Denmark and as most
of us know I think Denmark is a vastly
socialist society it is so beautifully
socialist that people don't even realize
it it's you grow up in this if you want
to use an example from from popular
culture the matrix it's an excellent way
of looking at how you grew up as a Dean
so fortunately someone unplugged me one
day I was flushed out how did that
happen was it a you know a book that you
read or something you saw or well I
think I've probably personally felt the
instinct for for a long time ever since
I was a teenager toward this
independence and the rebellion but I I
didn't know I couldn't put words on it
and when I look back on my my university
studies my dissertation and when I look
at a film I produced back then you know
it's it it was before I really knew
I was so so it was you know I
encountered you know this when I left
Denmark for the first time I met the man
who's not my husband rather than for che
and who's you know the hardcore Liberty
absolutely
happy new a for you left to write novels
full-time you worked at the Institute
for Humane studies which has been since
the early sixties have been kind of
bringing libertarian ideas to students
college students and graduate students
so you're fully in the mix but you know
why is is is fiction why do you find
fiction a and particularly historical
fiction a good vehicle for kind of
discussing ideas and you know and it's
your your the lost sisterhood which is a
great read it's not didactic in any kind
of heavy-handed or you know clubbing way
but like a lot of novels there's a lot
of ideas running through that why does
fiction work to convey no ideas as
opposed to why didn't you write a
philosophy book well obviously you know
for me I write fishes what I do I
couldn't sit down and write as many
teachers over the years have told me
this is not fiction and you know so and
and economists are wonderful at
discussing things and presenting things
to people who care to read about
economics but that is just one segment
of the readership and there's a vast
segment of the readership who who would
not read economics and and who go to
fiction and and I I I believe that most
people if they if they actually sit down
and think it through they probably are
libertarian you know if they're right
think how we define well of course
without the right thinking they agree
with you and they have a little when you
define well how do you define
libertarian that in that sense like how
are most people libertarian well okay so
how am most people they would never you
know we shouldn't think about it
necessarily in this way but but but
realized that that being told what's
good for you and having other people
make decisions for you is not a good
thing it will not lead to prosperity or
happiness overall and is that the for
you is that the ultimate message of the
lost sisterhood well I have to be well I
have to be very very careful right and
and I will say that there was a long
speech at the end of this book and I
wouldn't go as far as to say it was john
galt speech right no take two but it was
pretty long and it was pretty explicit
and that has been cut down by various
editorial attempts so I'm not I'm as you
say it's it's not
oh it's doesn't hammer home some sort of
message but I hope to raise a lot of
questions about the choices we make and
by being provocative and saying what if
what if a group of women decided that
they live to live outside of society and
bend the spoon and over override the
rules and regulations and norms that
society have set up for people well it
is we will leave it there no it's the
book is the lost sisterhood it's a novel
of ancient Amazon's contemporary
academics it's by an Fortier thank you
so much for talking to us thanks for
having for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie